what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime uproar and i finally decided
to dedicate an entire video to the
legendary red hair shanks a video that
will break down his secret master plan
that has been unfolding since chapter 1
of the one piece story shanks is
introduced at the very beginning he is
the man who saves luffy's life and
inspires his pirate adventure and yet
over 1 000 chapters later shanks remains
a huge mystery there has been a ton of
speculation surrounding him including
theories that he might be a villain but
personally i don't think shanks is evil
that said shanks is not just a carefree
drunken pirate than he pretends to be i
believe that he has a secret master plan
he has been methodical and even
machiavellian in executing this plan and
yes this plan does involve luffy and the
legendary nika devil fruit so let's get
into it you guys know the drill if you
enjoyed this one piece content and you
want us to keep it going just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you've been
watching our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet remember
that subscribing is a completely free
but very real way of directly supporting
the channel finally this video will
contain one piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned there are three main events
that are key to unlocking the mystery of
shanks
first is the fact that he went out of
his way to steal the devil fruit
formerly known as the gomugomi from the
world government
the second is the fact that he and his
overpowered crew spent over a year in a
small village in the east blue and the
third is the fact that he infiltrated
marijuana during the reverie in order to
take part in a secret meeting with the
gorosei but in order to get the full
picture we have to go back to the
beginning
shanks was born 39 years ago in the west
blue and by age 9 he was already a
pirate apprentice on the ship of the one
and only goldie roger so from a very
young age shanks and his frenemy buggy
were part of some of the most important
events taking place in the world at that
time shanks was part of the pirate
king's crew and he gained invaluable
knowledge and experience during this
time and although he did not personally
go to laughdale we have to assume that
shanks knows a lot more about the true
history of the world than we do 27 years
ago when shanks was about 12 the roger
pirates were confronted by the golden
lion pirates shiki the golden lion had
been informed that goldy roger had
knowledge of an ancient weapon and its
location and shiki wanted to team up
with roger and use that weapon to
conquer the world roger refused this
alliance because he was not interested
in taking over the world and a fierce
battle ensued now this might seem like
just one of the many events that shanks
would have witnessed as a member of
roger's crew but that part about an
ancient weapon is important
this event with shiki takes place before
roger hears the poseidon prophecy from
shirely on fishman island so this could
mean that the weapon which roger knew
about was one of the other two ancient
weapons pluton or uranus to be fair the
timeline of roger's adventures is not
exactly clear so we can't say for sure
that shiki wasn't talking about poseidon
but it is possible that roger knew about
another ancient weapon and that this
knowledge was passed on to shanks after
roger's death remember this because i
will come back to it later shanks was
about 14 years old when the roger
pirates disbanded and he was 15 when he
witnessed roger's public execution at
logtown rogers death launched the great
age of pirates and it is around this
time that shanks begins building his own
pirate crew he first asked the buggy to
join him but buggy refused and the two
of them went their separate ways all of
this took place 24 years before the
current events of the manga and 5 years
before the birth of monkey d luffy in
the years that followed shanks formed
the red hair pirates and two years after
roger's death he recruited usop's father
yasop eventually he recruited a whole
bunch of other pirates including ben
beckman lucky roo and rock star among
others shanks would also establish a
famous rivalry with the world's
strongest swordsman dracul mihawk and
their many duels were set to echo
throughout the grand line now a major
event occurred 12 years after roger's
death and 12 years before the present
time the red-haired pirates went out of
their way to steal a special devil fruit
from the world government this devil
fruit was the gomu gomo
and it was being carefully guarded
aboard a government ship the man in
charge of guarding the fruit was cp9
agent who's who and when he failed to
protect it he was imprisoned by the
world government that is how important
this one fruit was failing to protect it
led to severe punishment even for an
otherwise promising cp9 agent with a
pristine record interestingly enough
while in prison who's who heard the
legend of sun god nikka a warrior of
liberation who was worshiped by slaves
in ancient times after the guard who
told him about this legend suddenly
vanished who's who realized that
knowledge about sun god nika was
forbidden thinking that he might be
killed if he remained there who's who
risked his life in order to escape
prison and luckily for him he pulled it
off this part about sanga nika is of
course important because we later
learned that the very fruit that whose
who failed to protect the gomo gomonomi
was actually a legendary mythical zone
fruit whose real name is the hitohitomi
model nika it is not clear whether the
red hair pirates knew that the devil
fruit was special before they stole it
although the fact that they went out of
their way to steal it from the
government suggests that they knew
something don't forget that shanks is
known for being cautious and diplomatic
and in general he is a man of peace he
is even recognized as such by the world
government so for him to go out of his
way to create an incident with the world
government over this one devil fruit
suggests that he had a pretty good idea
of the value of this fruit and after
shanks and the red hair pirates obtained
the nika fruit they proceeded to do
something highly suspicious despite
being one of the strongest pirate crews
in the world the red hair pirates
decided to spend a whole year in and
around a small village in the east blue
keep in mind that the east blue is
commonly known as the weakest and most
peaceful of all the seas and although
some strong characters come from the
east blue like roger garp and the dragon
in general the pirates of the east blue
are seen as weak when compared to the
pirates in the rest of the world so why
would shanks a man who would go on to
become a yonko only five or six years
after leaving fusha village spend an
entire year there just hanging out at a
bar arguing with a little kid and
leaving the legendary fruit that he
stole from the world government within
the reach of that same little kid this
brings us to the events of the very
first chapter of the one piece manga and
knowing everything we know now there is
a lot to unpack here beyond the fact
that shanks spent a whole year hanging
out in fusha village in the first place
there are other odd aspects about his
behavior in that first chapter for
example he is incredibly dismissive of
the idea that a seven-year-old luffy
could join his crew and become a pirate
he says that it's impossible for luffy
to become a pirate because he is too
young and also because he doesn't know
how to swim and a pirate has to be able
to swim but both of these arguments are
odd because first up shanks was around
luffy's age when he himself became an
apprentice pirate on the oro jackson
depending on when exactly he joined the
roger pirates he may have been only like
a year older than luffy maybe two years
tops beyond that shanks knows very well
that plenty of powerful pirates cannot
swim because they've eaten devil fruits
in fact all of the yonko except for
shanks are confirmed devil fruit users
so again shanks's dismissal luffy
doesn't make much sense then there's
that whole incident with higuma the bear
the leader of the mountain bandits
during their first encounter higuma
insults shanks and spills grog all over
him but shanks just takes the abuse
calmly until higum and his men get bored
and lee shanks does this despite the
fact that we know he and his crew are
far stronger than higuma when luffy
confronts him about the fact that he
didn't defend himself shanks explains it
away by saying that no harm was done and
there's no reason to kill a man over
some spilled drinks shanks comes off as
a man with no ego who doesn't care one
bit how others treat him or what they
think of him which i have to admit is
pretty zen stoic and badass at the same
time but what if the real reason why
shanks reacted this way isn't just that
he is egoless and pacifistic what if
shanks's reaction or lack thereof to
higuma's provocations is also related to
the real reason why the red hair pirates
are spending so much time in fusha
village in the first place
what if shanks and his crew are
determined to maintain a low profile
because of the sensitive nature of their
real mission and they know that if they
got into a fight with the bandits they
would draw too much attention to
themselves later on shanks and his crew
do end up dispatching higumine the
bandits after the bandits threatened
luffy's life but not long after that
they depart fusha village for good so
what were they doing there for so long
in one of his videos manu aka ohara said
that shanks may have been looking for
roger's son ace because he may have
believed that ace would be the inheritor
of his father's will that may well have
been shanks's true purpose and in my
opinion something like that makes far
more sense than just having him randomly
decide to spend the entire year in this
place i find it very difficult to
believe that shanks and his crew
wouldn't be able to find ace if that was
their real mission since ace was hiding
out on a mountain just behind the
village if shanks had enough intel to
look for ace in fuchsia village he would
certainly have been able to find him on
that mountain after a year of searching
but maybe shanks wasn't looking for ace
specifically maybe he was looking for
the rightful user of the gomu gomunomi
devil fruit we recently learned from the
gorosei that the gomu gomu nomi aka the
nika devil fruit has a will of its own
and it is as if this devil fruit has
been deliberately running away from the
world government for centuries if we
assume that shanks knew more about the
nika fruit than he let on initially he
may have been trying to determine whom
the nika fruit itself wanted to go to
next somehow shanks had the feeling that
the fruit wanted to be in fuchsia and
since ace was nearby as well shanks may
have been waiting for ace to eat it i
mean it's hard to understand why the red
hair pirates would have left the fruit
unguarded within the reach of a random
kid unless shanks was relying on fate or
on the fruit itself to determine who is
worthy of consuming it and in the end as
we know the fruit chose luffy soon after
the fruit was eaten the red hair pirates
packed up and left fuchsia although not
before shanks saved luffy's life
sacrificing an arm in the process and
then giving luffy his straw hat along
with a lifetime supply of motivation to
become a great pirate but then the big
question is this
if shanks knew the true power of the
nika fruit and he had been waiting for
the fruit to choose its next user why
wouldn't he take luffy with him why
would shanks leave luffy's safety up to
fate instead of taking him along and
grooming him into the perfect vessel for
the nika fruit honestly the best
explanation i have for this is that
shanks didn't want the world government
to know about luffy and that he was the
new user of the nika fruit if luffy had
traveled with shanks he likely would
have been on the government's radar
right away and the secret would be out
immediately by leaving luffy in a small
village in the east blue shanks allowed
luffy to grow and develop his powers
with relative anonymity which protected
him from becoming a target for the world
government and of course as a marine
garp was the ideal person to protect
luffy from unwanted attention by the
world government something that shanks
could never give him i mean the fact
that garp decided to take luffy up into
the mountains and place him in the care
of curly dadan right after he developed
his rubber powers seems to back up this
line of thinking instead of having luffy
walking around town and showing everyone
his rubber powers on a daily basis he
was taken to a much more discreet
location up in the mountains where he
would draw a lot less attention and even
though shanks left luffy all those years
ago he has been keeping tabs on him and
his adventures as was shown multiple
times shanks has also been engaging in
some serious politics and diplomacy he
stopped the war at marine ford before
even more damage was done to luffy and
the whitebeard pirates and he prevented
kaido from intercepting the whitebeard
pirates on their way to marineford we
know that shanks promised to meet up
with luffy again once luffy became a
great pirate so we know that luffy is
still part of shanks's master plan but
what is that master plan why is shanks
doing everything that he's been doing
including the theft of the nika fruit
the mysterious stay in fuchsia his rise
to the status of yonko and so on what is
shanks really up to for the answer to
that we have to go back to his shocking
and highly secretive private meeting
with the gorosei during the reverie as i
mentioned earlier during the reverie
shanks infiltrates pangaea castle the
base of operations for the world
government
there he gains a private audience with
the gorosei themselves with the intent
of discussing quote unquote a certain
pirate but perhaps even more surprising
than shanks showing up there in the
first place is the reaction of the
gorosei to shanks's presence they appear
to be only mildly surprised to see him
and they are certainly not shocked or
intimidated by the fact that he is here
in fact they even dismiss their security
guards so that they can speak to shanks
privately this indicates a certain level
of trust between shanks and the gorosei
and the reaction of the gorosei to
shanks's visit tells me that this is not
the first private meeting they've had i
believe that shanks has met with them in
secret multiple times and so the big
question then is why why is shanks
engaging in secret dealings with the
rulers of the world government a
tyrannical regime that he presumably
wants to destroy proponents of the
villain shanks theory have argued that
shanks is working with the world
government and that he is luring luffy
and other key players into a trap but i
don't think that shanks is a villain
that said i do think that shanks is far
more machiavellian than he made himself
out to be in early one piece and i
believe that his secret dealings with
the gorosei are part of his strategy to
outmaneuver the other yonko and
especially blackbeard and speaking of
blackbeard when shanks says to the
gorosei that he is here to discuss a
certain pirate most people automatically
assumed that he was talking about
blackbeard after all he tried to warn
people about blackbeard before including
whitebeard on more than one occasion but
at the same time it's fair to say that
at this point in the story the gorosei
don't really need any more warnings
about blackbeard they are fully aware of
what a massive threat he poses to the
stability of the entire world like sure
shanks may have some additional
information about blackbeard's creepy
powers and special devil fruits that the
gorosei may not know about but it is
also possible that shanks was there to
talk about another pirate altogether the
villain shanks theorists believed that
he was there to warn them about luffy
and the fact that he was about to awaken
the nica devil fruit this is why the
gorosei abruptly ordered the cp-0 agent
on wano to kill luffy immediately no
matter the cost
but it doesn't make sense for shanks to
sacrifice his own arm to save luffy's
life only to try to get luffy killed
later on this scenario would only make
sense if shanks knew that luffy needed
to die before his devil fruit awakened
and he was brought back to life because
that is exactly what ended up happening
luffy died in the fight against kaido
his heart stopped but then it started
beating again as the nika fruit awakened
for the first time in 800 years and as
zunisha declared that joyboy has
returned if shanks knew that luffy was
now ready to awaken his devil fruit and
if he knew that luffy had to first die
in order to awaken it then the idea that
he might have tricked the gorosei into
having luffy killed begins to make some
more sense
and this brings me all the way back to
roger and that ancient weapon that he
knew about back when he was confronted
by shiki i recently made an entire video
talking about the possibility that
joyboy may actually be the ancient
weapon uranus and that the nika devil
fruit could be the catalyst for actually
activating this ancient weapon poseidon
is associated with the sea and has taken
the form of shirahoshi pluton is
supposedly a massive battleship that is
hidden somewhere on alabasta and uranus
a weapon whose name is associated with
the sky and the heavens is actually sun
god nika be sure to check out that full
video if you're interested there are too
many details to get into here but i will
link it down in the description however
i do want to bring up one interesting
detail that was pointed out to me in the
comments of that uranus video by a user
named dylan davis dylan pointed out that
at the end of episode 126 of the one
piece anime we see king cobra of
alabasta standing in front of three
symbols that are written in the style of
ancient hieroglyphics these symbols are
a boat a sea monster slash sea king and
the sun pluton poseidon uranus a warship
a force that can command the sea kings
and finally sun god nika if this theory
is correct then the ancient weapon that
roger knew about may have been uranus he
knew the truth about the nika devil
fruit and he passed that knowledge onto
shanks
shanks then went out of his way to steal
this fruit he let the fruit itself
choose its next user and he kept an eye
on this user and protected him from afar
until the user reached the point at
which shanks believed that he was ready
to awaken the true power of nika joyboy
and uranus knowing that luffy must first
die before fully unlocking this ancient
power shanks instructs the gorosei to
kill him but little did the goro say
know that by killing luffy they didn't
eliminate him as a threat rather they
created the very threat that they were
trying to eliminate shirahoshi and luffy
are the two sovereigns mentioned in the
prophecy just like shirahoshi is the
ancient weapon poseidon luffy has become
the ancient weapon uranus and shanks can
now use that weapon to finally bring his
master plan to fruition and of course
that plan can only be one thing to
defeat both blackbeard and the world
government and to usher in a new world
the kind of world that roger wanted to
create the same kind of world that
joyboy wanted to create and the same
kind of world that luffy wants to create
a world where freedom triumphs over
tyranny where joy triumphs over sorrow
and where every man and woman are free
to embrace their own great adventure but
massive global revolutions don't just
happen by themselves and they don't just
happen because you want it to happen the
overthrow of the world government and
the arrival of a new dawn and a new
world requires masterful strategy
skillful diplomacy and machiavellian
political tactics these are not things
that luffy has ever been very good at
but this is where shanks comes in that
is what shanks has been doing all this
time he has been betting on the new era
he has been setting the stage for the
revolution and he has been overseeing
the growth of the ultimate weapon in his
arsenal monkey d luffy
i will say that i find it a bit odd that
none of the red hair pirates seem to be
devil fruit users at least none of them
are confirmed to be all the other yonko
have been devil fruit users and many of
their crew members are as well since
shanks made a big deal about being able
to swim back in that first chapter i
wonder if there is some specific reason
why the red hair pirates need to retain
their ability to swim like maybe in
order to get to laughtale you need to
actually physically swim part of the way
like through an underwater cave or
something and if there isn't some big
reason why the red hair pirates need to
retain their ability to swim i wonder if
shanks will end up consuming a devil
fruit at some point in the future maybe
the nika fruit wasn't the only legendary
devil fruit that shanks was able to
locate and with mythical zones being all
the rage right now it will be extremely
cool to see shanks reveal a godly
mythical zone ability of his own
personally i hope that it will be a
devil fruit that suits his color scheme
so like some sort of red dragon zone or
maybe a god of war mars zone that kind
of thing let me know what you guys think
will shanks ever get a devil fruit and
if not is there a specific reason for
that also what do you think is shanks's
master plan did he know the truth about
the nika fruit before he stole it why
did he spend a year in fusha village why
did he meet privately with the gorosei
let me know down below if you guys
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more one piece content in the future
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps with that
youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
but very important way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys